first thing we got to do to get the bike
braids cancelled is raise awareness yeah
we're gonna need poster boards markers
and lots of glitter and glue
I can't believe Kenny bailed on us just
because he thinks jeff bezos is a bad
guy yeah how can somebody who gives you
a never you Bobby a bad guy they're
closed
we're all closed our coffee shop
everything but we're outraged about
something we need later a new yeah well
when the Amazon Fulfillment Center
opened everything else went out of
business I let it happen
I thought the fulfillment center would
be nothing but great for the town
instead it's it's buried us but it's
Christmas it's Christmas and with no
presents no decorations there's no one
who can help
[Applause]
I heard some people here might need a
little Christmas magic
we sure do Santa it's only a couple
weeks until Christmas and we don't have
any presents well that's no problem for
the hometown of my favorite holiday Pooh
where is mr. Hankey where is that old
bundle of Christmas cheer we well we had
to get rid of mr. Hankey got rid of him
mr. Hankey did something bad and we were
forced to make him leave forever Jesus
what'd he do a kid no he he tweeted some
inappropriate things he tweeted some
inappropriate things oh you betcha I'm
getting back in my sleigh now Merry
Christmas
have fun second Jeff business's digging
a bunch of
[Music]
myself